how's it going red - brother Pat and
welcome back to some more sexiness so
let's see one more ragin tears lies
ahead wow that sure was a tough bonfire
daddy yes I don't know if this is good
but I'm gonna wear it the entire rest of
the plate hahaha oh god what's gonna
happen here hi oh [ __ ]
no bad iceberg anyone else you wanna
dance baby
oh you wanna Dane huh slap that on oh
gosh what no I thought I was dead but I
was the sexy bog is angry he thirst for
blood
oh yeah me what what where the hell did
he come from am I supposed to keep track
of all the icebergs
it looks like he's cooking something
nice attack oh oh god more sorry I can't
all your friends help you don't mind hi
I got Debbie's is it tough he's telling
you what a [ __ ] what a guy damn [ __ ] -
burning hell [ __ ] he's coming
with me that's you weren't invited
sorry you need to work on your aim brah
I'm just saying you're pretty [ __ ]
bad at this
good night no one loves me no one cares
about my killing me does not mean you
care I'm naked one at a time ladies
but not a time oh god I'm so [ __ ]
sorry s focaccia at Tim about ya actin
god damn it what if I just [ __ ] them
all at once [ __ ] them all at once [ __ ]
them all at once [ __ ] all the icebergs
at once
I worked I'm naked and I know it
who what the hell there's no boss in
here what is oh god everyone help okay
you're covering the screen you dick
whoa whoa this looks like with the place
to be see anywhere you go in this game
it just looks stunning like this game is
so cool space butterfly tell me where to
go
what as a trend-setting bor one said
Yolo oh now you're telling me thanks we
be guys and we be blazing we be tracing
we'll be facing this is Oh whatta [ __ ]
are you ah ostriches with sexy legs now
I've seen it all man I am beautiful
and you are [ __ ] ugly and words can
change that no no I'm a boy or no in
every single way what I did a little
spin thing and you still hit me that
that just you just broke the laws of
[ __ ] physics wait I can't see what's
going on I can't [ __ ] see how
ostriches are they call us address
ostrich ostriches I Google ostriches
there's no such thing I don't [ __ ]
know what I'm talking about
well this helmet is badass I love this
outfit hello it is so [ __ ] cool
whoever designed stuff in this [ __ ]
game is swag Lord mm or something
whatever shows up next will see my
today's really no one oh there you go
bang come here you'll get to see my
boobs you can almost see them I'm
showing I'm showing there so just look
at that it's wrong man that [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] this is not a wide light this is
black this game is racist
I want that [ __ ] are you
what in the heaven's name did cause that
abominable damn it I better above it
ah ba ba ba Casa de neige check all your
netball I don't know what's going on
okay it seems to be working Oh what is
that it must be his life source goodbye
you ugly ass dragon I don't even know
what's going haha oh God
he's faced towards me that's not that
can't be a good thing oh god how am I
supposed to survive against day don't
mind me
don't mind me don't mind me you're
racist against fogs man okay what are we
what are we gonna do with you man you
have a nice tits okay let's just hit his
nipples a little bit just to it's a nice
way to say hi I guess oh god he's scary
my God he's scary help you like it then
you share the cotton apples off if
you're like a dinoshona cotton it I
don't know why but if this tactic seems
to work I'm ignoring everything and just
trying to cut this piece of [ __ ] stop
running away from me girl oh [ __ ] oh god
I'm so [ __ ] out
where am I come on we're so close I have
five [ __ ] Estus come on come on
did I [ __ ] throw that [ __ ] no no did
I what what is he supposed to be easy
what killed the dinosaurs guys a bonfire
where were you before man I missed you
man brofist okay so let's go to
apparently there's a bossing fire link
but I am the child Oh God
what okay we need to go to the graveyard
I remember having so much trouble with
these guys holy [ __ ] what a difference
oh this one looks a little scarier
nevermind
binoculars I should have used those add
here we go that fanservice haha
where the hell are we going I don't like
this the catacombs what I didn't I don't
know it was flying come on
kingi bonfire what happens if I click
this that's exactly what I hope for
oh dude that's ah ah this shoes our
product oh oh they're all ah ah ah
[ __ ] this place man
come on don't run away from me fool slap
your eyes the hell is going on here hey
guys no just me senpai
god damnit I don't know if I should jump
or not that would be a no I should not
have [ __ ] job ah am I supposed to be
here woah hi okay let's try and kill him
I rarely steal his loot what wheels I
thought you were on my side wheels Oh
God not those things
come on wheels come down we can't be
friends why don't you like me wheels oh
they're actually just skeletons that's a
bit of a disappointment actually oh they
give you a lot of souls man one of them
is stuck in my this will make a great
skirt we shall go forever come on while
I was almost forever where am I supposed
to go I feel like I'm gonna die if I
jump down there I'm probably gonna die
anyway so what what is happening
that looks [ __ ] scary man this game
is [ __ ] terrifying I don't even have
a bonfire oh cool
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt
anything
oh oh god that's a cool boss okay hi
this is very Legend of Zelda well that
went fantastic
no oh hey Oh
shortcuts oh god she's [ __ ] scared
nice nice beard man it's pretty oh cool
is he is he a bro oh sorry
this game is strange I love it
I think I killed one of them tall
I'm sorry what I'm sorry what whoa
what so where do we go now shortcut
ahead oh come on
I'll come on come on this place is gonna
be a nightmare
good job heads awful [ __ ] sake exact
[ __ ] god [ __ ] oh I can't walk here
took me forever to realize Yolo yeah no
hey hey what the [ __ ] are you doing here
what the hell okay
lewd nice what that [ __ ] you dick
it's so me alright Prez I'm gonna have
to end episode here hope you enjoyed
watching they were like if you did I
really appreciate it hit this guy come
over today I see you bros in the next
one a lot of projects in this one I'm
afraid of proud thousand brothers love
you
we're gonna do another piece the stupid
thing it's been forever let's do this
please a cookie on your forehead and try
and heat it without using your hands
oh wow guys hey guys hi guys I eat